CHERIE HANNOUCHE: Good
afternoon, everyone.
And thank you guys so
much for coming out, even
with the weather.
My name is Cherie
Hannouche, and I
work in the education team in
Large Customer Sales for GBO.
And I am thrilled today to
introduce two-time Pulitzer
Prize winner, Nicholas Kristof,
and award-winning producer
and head of Show of
Force, Mira Chang.
Today we're going to talk a
little bit about their newest
documentary, "A Path Appears--
Transforming Lives and Creating
Opportunity," which is based
on the book of the same title
that Nicholas wrote with
his wife, Sheryl WuDunn.
So I'm going to tell
you a little bit
about the documentary.
We're going to play a quick
clip and then bring them up.
So the actual documentary
follows advocates and actors,
including Malin Akerman,
Blake Lively, Jennifer Garner,
Mia Farrow, Alfre Woodard, as
they travel to Kenya, Colombia,
Haiti, as well as
the United States.
And they uncovered different
parts of human rights
violations and the
effective solutions
being implemented
to combat them.
Nicholas Kristof is an
award-winning journalist,
a recognized humanitarian,
a bestselling author,
and a "New York
Times" columnist.
In 1990, he won a Pulitzer
with his wife Sheryl WuDunn,
for their coverage of
China's Tiananmen Square.
He won a second Pulitzer
in 2006 for his columns
on the genocide in
Darfur, that are
said to have single-handedly
focused Americans
on the attention and atrocities
committed during that time.
Nicholas has been credited for
reshaping the field of opinion
journalism and for
being, and I quote,
"the conscience of
international journalism."
Through his writings
and initiatives,
he's done a lot to shine a
light on gender oppression,
human rights violations, and
social and economic justice
around the world, and
call on us to do our share
to make the world
a better place.
Mira Chang is a producer,
director, and director
of photography of
nonfiction content
for domestic and
international television,
and several full-length
documentaries, as well.
Her work can be seen regularly
on ABC, National Geographic,
A&E, and Discovery, and
she's been nominated
for several Emmys, as
well as Academy Awards.
Mira also produced the landmark
four-hour PBS documentary,
"Half the Sky-- Turning
Oppression Into Opportunity
for Women Worldwide,"
which was based
on the bestselling book
with the same title
that Nicholas and
his wife wrote.
She's currently heading up the
development at Show of Force.
And we've got some of
them here with us today.
So welcome.
And they are the creative
enterprise behind two PBS
documentaries with
Kristof, and a number
of Emmy-winning
projects, as well.
So I'm going to just show
a quick clip of the trailer
of the three-part series,
which is airing tonight on PBS,
as well as next Monday.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
-Our new project is
called, "A Path Appears."
The title is from Lu Xun,
a prominent Chinese writer,
who said that hope is like
a path in the countryside.
At first, there is no path.
But as more and
more people walk,
again and again, a path appears.
Meaning a solution appears.
It's about innovative strategies
for making a difference.
In "Half the Sky,"
we were asking
how do you begin
to tackle seemingly
insurmountable problems?
Is that red door-- is that
a brothel, do we think?
-Yes, it is.
-She doesn't have
a radial pulse.
-Just stay safe, OK?
-In "A Path Appears," we
take it to a new level.
We actually look at the
roots of vulnerability.
And we talk about solutions
that really address those roots.
-It's easier to look at
problems outside the country
than it is to look at
stuff in our own backyard.
-More than 300,000 girls
go missing each year.
-In the United States?
-In the US.
And 100,000 of them are
sold for sex in some form.
-Nick and Sheryl use stories
to capture attention.
-Police.
You're under arrest.
OK.
Let's sit tight.
-That's not the reality.
This is the reality.
-Like, every day.
-Because stories are powerful.
-That's her.
-That's her?
-That's Niaomi.
-[INAUDIBLE]
-From Haiti, to Chicago, from
Colombia, to Kenya, to Boston.
The central problem, as
we see it, is poverty.
-This trailer is
a home where they
said they may have
14 people at a time.
-Yes.
-Poverty is much more than
just not having enough money.
It's not having hope.
-From sex trafficking,
to teen pregnancy,
to unemployment,
to substance abuse,
to violence against
women-- Sheryl and I
are traveling to new
parts of the world.
-It's overwhelming.
I don't know if I've seen
this much despair before.
You're lucky if you're
just struggling.
The vast majority
are just alive.
-At any given moment, it
could turn ugly and violent.
-Sheryl and I are sharing real
human stories of struggle,
and challenge, and
transformation.
-I am tired.
-Are you tired?
-Yeah.
-Are you ready to go today?
-No.
-None of these problems
exist in isolation.
-She had 14 kids.
-And those babies are
going to grow up poor.
And they're going to remain in
the cycle of poverty forever.
-We now understand how
a tiny intervention
can have a transformative
impact on a child's life
a generation later.
-Oh, wow.
Yes.
[CHILDREN CHANTING]
-As we take our
journey, we're going
to be inviting
along actors to try
to highlight not just the
problems, but the ways to chip
away at them.
-I am Ashley.
I'm a grateful, recovering,
depressed co-dependent.
A survivor of all
forms of sexual abuse,
including incest and rape.
And about that, I have no shame
-Welcome to the circle.
-I feel like I've discovered
this darkness that
lives in our country.
And this isn't falling
through the cracks.
This is an earthquake.
-It's important to
keep bearing witness,
keep telling the story.
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
-Our world is now
a global village.
-We look at these
monumental problems.
They seem so daunting.
But we can change the
course of history.
We can set these young
children onto a much more
promising path.
-One girl at a time, hey?
-It all goes back to early
childhood intervention.
In this country, and of
course, around the world.
-What you have to do is
dream about the future
and have hope for the future.
And that's how the
future changes.
-I know I can save you.
Just say something.
Just open your mouth and
tell me so that I can fix it.
You know--
-There is a solution.
It takes the parents.
It takes the teachers.
It takes the whole community.
It's just up to us to care.
-I definitely walk
away feeling hopeful.
I think that we are
capable of great things.
-Everyone, everywhere, can
have an impact in humanity.
Through hope we can
achieve our dreams.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[END PLAYBACK]
CHERIE HANNOUCHE: Everyone,
please welcome Nicholas Kristof
and Mira Chang.
[APPLAUSE]
NICHOLAS KRISTOF: Thanks a lot.
MIRA CHANG: Hi.
Thank you.
CHERIE HANNOUCHE:
Thank you very much.
Hi.
Thank you.
NICHOLAS KRISTOF: I was
almost-- take your seat.
Oh, hey-- it's totally fine.
CHERIE HANNOUCHE: Thank you guys
so much for joining us today.
We really appreciate it.
NICHOLAS KRISTOF: Thanks a lot.
CHERIE HANNOUCHE: That's great.
NICHOLAS KRISTOF: Thank
you all for bringing
this incredibly
well-smelling food, too.
[LAUGHTER]
CHERIE HANNOUCHE: Lunch
hour-- perfect timing, right?
Guys, can you tell us
just a little bit more
about "A Path Appears"?
Both the book and
the documentary
explore gender inequality.
Where does the actual
title come from?
NICHOLAS KRISTOF:
So let me tell you
about the origins of the book.
After Sheryl and I-- and
Sheryl sends her regrets--
I hate to admit this in the
discussion of gender equality,
but she's actually
at home, probably
right now shoveling
our driveway.
So I got the better end
of the stick right here.
And so she sends her regards.
She would much rather, I
think, be here, as well.
But after we wrote
"Half the Sky,"
and after the "Half
the Sky" documentary
that Mira had also
worked on, then that
had really focused on
empowering women abroad.
And after that, we got a
couple of kinds of questions.
One, what about the situation
right here in the US?
And secondly, so what can I do?
What are the solutions?
And we wanted to
come back and look
at ways one can
make a difference.
It does seem to us that,
by and large, people
do want to find a little
more purpose in life,
make a difference-- especially
millennials, for that matter.
And that there really is
evidence now about what works,
what doesn't work.
And that there
are-- sometimes it
becomes a little bit too easy
to point to problems abroad,
when we also have huge
problems right here.
It's too easy to pit
them against each other
and say, either we should
solve our own problems first,
before worrying about Tanzania,
or to say the opposite--
that we should just
focus on problems abroad.
There are huge problems
both here and abroad,
and we wanted to
offer some windows
into how to address them.
MIRA CHANG: And a lot of those
problems people just don't see.
When we were talking
about "Half the Sky,"
and were talking about maternal
mortality, and trafficking,
violence against women,
people don't even
know the extent of what
happens here in the US.
And even back when "Half
the Sky" was being produced,
we kept thinking
about it would be
amazing to be able to
shed light on what's
happening here in our country.
Because I don't think it's
really discussed a lot.
So that was one of our hopes
for "A Path Appears," as well.
And then hopefully, people
walk away with that.
CHERIE HANNOUCHE: I like, also,
the different ways that you're
also reaching those audiences.
You mention Millennials.
And I think, of
course, Millenials
do get this bad rap of being
lazy or not as involved.
And yet, even in 2014,
there were reports
from the Millennial
path report that
talked about the high
percentages of Millennials
who have given back, and who
have volunteered their time,
and have made contributions.
What are some of
the ways that we
can communicate to Millennials
to encourage them to give back?
NICHOLAS KRISTOF: So there
is apathappears.org website
that does list some
ways of engaging.
And likewise, in
the back of the book
there are a bunch of
great organizations,
as well as a list of things you
can do in the next 10 minutes,
for example.
And what you choose,
there's no one right answer
about what to do.
It depends a little bit
what you care about,
what your passions are.
Broadly, there are
three kinds of things.
You can donate,
you can volunteer,
or you can engage in advocacy.
On the issue of
Millenials, though, I
think one of the things that
corporate America hasn't woken
up to is that corporations
really can do,
I think, a much better job with
corporate social responsibility
programs.
And so far, CSR has
been kind of a joke--
really window dressing, largely.
And it would be great
if the tech sector
showed some real
leadership here.
Partly because so
many of the employees
are millennials,
because companies
tend to emphasize values,
have brands they care about.
And in fact, the tech sector
has underperformed, I'd say,
in CSR.
CHERIE HANNOUCHE:
And it's interesting
because, at Google, I think we
are very fortunate that we have
different ways to give
back-- our GoogleServe, which
is a week dedicated
to giving back,
as well as a Google
match program.
But as you mentioned,
not all tech companies
have that on par, and that
has been very important
for Millennials.
They really do care about
the type of organization
that they work for and
what they stand for.
What are some ways-- can
you talk a little bit more
about some ways that Silicon
Valley or tech companies
can stand up?
NICHOLAS KRISTOF: Well, I
think that a CSR program that
actually involved employees,
that gave them a choice,
gave them a vote--
do you want to adopt
this cause, or that
cause, gave them
a chance to volunteer in East
Palo Alto-- where I don't what
proportion of kids are
below the poverty line,
but is right next door to so
many very successful companies.
And on some of
the issues that we
talk about in the documentary or
in the book-- sex trafficking.
It would be incredibly powerful
if there were tools addressed
to-- I mean, these kids
are advertised on the web.
And I think that reflects kind
of an acquiescence on our part
that these girls don't matter.
We would not allow fully
automatic machine guns,
or RPGs to be sold on the web,
or large quantities of meth.
Silk Road is now closed
down for that reason.
But we do allow 100,000 girls
each year, approximately--
underage girls-- to
be sold on the web,
on organizations like BackPage.
.
I think it's a
function of priority.
So I'd love to see
companies get involved
to try to provide tools to
address this, provide volunteer
opportunities, and ways of
engaging employees in such
that that would, I
think, boost the brand,
and boost morale, and
create a-- and I think
it used to be that
the way we engage
was we would write checks
at the end of the year.
I think that, more and
more, for your generation,
you are trying to
make a difference,
not just by writing checks
but in the consumer decisions
you're making-- what you buy,
and the company that you work
for, in the
investments you make.
And I don't think the corporate
sector has fully woken up
to the benefits
from really engaging
in ways that would help
recruitment and retention,
and actually be in
their own as well.
CHERIE HANNOUCHE: Interesting.
I think one of things on that,
because the three-part series--
it actually aired, the
first part, last Monday.
And we had a small
Google session
of people who talked
about the first part
the next day at breakfast.
And one of the things
that actually surprised me
was how many people shared
the same sentiments of some
of the advocates and
actors in the piece,
of not knowing that
this is happening
in your backyard in the US--
Boston, Nashville, right there.
I think that's one
of the things that--
NICHOLAS KRISTOF: Or Times
Square, if we're right here.
CHERIE HANNOUCHE: Exactly.
What are some of
the things that you
think-- what are some of the
reasons you think that that's
not being shared or
broadcasted as much?
And people are thinking it's
happening in India, or very far
away.
NICHOLAS KRISTOF: And I think
there are two misunderstandings
that we have about sex
trafficking in the US.
One is we tend to think it
involves foreign women being
smuggled into the US.
And that's real.
That happens, especially both
with Asians and with Latinas,
in particular.
But the bigger part
of the problem,
and especially involving
underage girls,
is homegrown American girls.
And this is-- obviously, it
involves all kinds of girls.
But often, it's girls
who have grown up
in disadvantaged communities.
They may have endured sexual
abuse at a very young age
and they have
self-esteem issues.
And then, typically, they have
maybe a tough relationship
with their mom.
Then Mom's boyfriend
is hitting on them.
They run away at age 13 to
say, the Port Authority.
And who's looking
for them there?
It's the pimps.
And so 100,000 underage kids
a year-- well, 1.6 million
are runaway each
year in the US--
and of those, about 100,000 are
trafficked into the sex trade.
And I think the other
misunderstanding we have is we
see a 15-year-old girl
out on the street.
She's wearing
inappropriate clothing.
Nobody's holding
a gun to her head.
We assume that she is there
because she wants to be.
And it is so much more
complicated than that.
And it's true that
it's not as if she
is physically being
handcuffed to a radiator,
or locked up in a closet
somewhere-- and that happens,
but that's much less common.
But the kinds of control, and
coercion, and intimidation,
and violence that control these
teenage girls are very real
and make it far from this sort
of happy, voluntary situation
that we tend to impute to it.
Do you--
MIRA CHANG: I think
that a lot of it
is changing for the better,
in terms of awareness.
But there's still
a long way to go.
I think, maybe 10 years
ago, I did a documentary
about teen prostitutes,
where today we
would call it trafficking.
So I think a lot of
it is that there's
some perception from the public
that the idea of prostitution
has a lot of choice
involved in it.
But when you speak to
the trafficking survivors
or prostitutes who have
been arrested, like,
160 times, it always goes
back-- if you peel back
the layers-- to some
really common roots
about difficult home lives,
and a great deal of abuse,
sexual and otherwise,
from an early age.
So we have to start thinking
about it differently, and also
understanding that there's
not one thing to do.
We worked a lot with law
enforcement, and all of them
are trying to figure out
now how to approach it.
And they realize it's
not just one thing.
They need to work
with survivors.
They need to work with
the justice system.
And they need to treat the
demand side differently.
So yeah.
I think things are changing.
But it's a lot about
awareness and understanding
that these issues
are taking place,
and how you could, just
by understanding it
in a different way,
help move it a bit.
CHERIE HANNOUCHE: It seems
like awareness is key.
But then also, as you
mentioned, those complications.
That it's not something that
you might see on the street,
what's actually really there.
And in the documentary
from last Monday,
there was one scene
that-- we'd love
to just show a clip of that.
That just really painted
a very clear picture
of what's happening.
And it tells the story of a
young girl named Savannah.
I just want to show
that clip real quick.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
-Thank you, guys, for sitting
down and talking to to me, too.
-Sure.
-I really appreciate it.
-Ms. Savannah's
just got back home.
She was in a group
home for a while.
For--
-Well, I was in a
hospital for nine months.
And then a group home
for, like, three.
-When we have visits this
is kind of what we do.
We'll meet at, like,
a coffee shop--
-Savannah is a
17-year-old girl who
turned out to have
been trafficked
when she was just 13, and
who ultimately was locked up
in a house by a pimp,
and truly enslaved,
in any sense of that word.
-So one day, I think I
was 13, I didn't really
know a lot about anything.
So I went online
and I wanted to-- I
don't know how I
came across, like,
this website for,
like, sugar daddies.
Guys would pay for
your stuff and you
would have sex with them.
I didn't know that I would
have to have sex with them.
I just thought they
were going to-- I
don't know what I was thinking.
But I just thought that
they would buy me stuff,
just because I was pretty.
I don't know.
But yeah, he took me shopping.
And then we went--
and I still did not
understand what was
happening, like, completely.
Even when we went to the
hotel room, until it happened.
And then I was still a virgin.
But that was my first
time with an old guy.
And he said he was
taking some pictures.
And I knew-- like, I knew what
kind of pictures they would be,
like, I thought.
But I didn't really know that
they would be put it online
and I would be doing
all this other stuff.
-Society's idea of what a
woman is that sells her body--
you think of this woman who
is, like, hardened and callous,
and she doesn't care.
But when you think of that,
you don't think of someone
like Savannah, who's
done all of those things
that we think of a
prostitute as doing.
You don't ever think of someone
being vulnerable, and being
broken, and wanting to
get out of that life,
and wanting to be a
little girl again.
You don't think of
them as little girls.
-He hit me a few times.
And then he had a gun
and he pointed it at me.
And he was, like, you
need to do what I say.
He was, like, I will kill you.
He thought that the moment
he put the gun to my head,
like, he had me-- that
I wasn't going to leave.
-To see Savannah
was to see the face
of the reality of what
it is in our country.
And that was the most
profound thing for me.
-You think about
your partner, who
you love and love
having sex with.
You think about having to
have sex with that person
that you love and adore,
10 to 20 times a day.
Now think about survivors
and kids in the life.
They have to sleep with 10
to 20 strangers per night.
Who would ever choose to
do something like that?
[END PLAYBACK]
CHERIE HANNOUCHE: I think
when we look at that,
that in itself shows some of the
differences of those subtleties
and complexities we see
happening in the US versus some
of the other parts of the world.
But the documentary does explore
Kenya, and Haiti, and Colombia.
What are some of the
differences, when we're
looking at those global issues
and gender inequalities,
between the different places?
NICHOLAS KRISTOF: There's no
doubt that poverty in America
starts at a material
level and an education
level that is much greater.
So there are plenty
of people who
are poor in America who have a
vehicle, who have a home that
is more than just a shack,
that has electricity,
this kind of thing.
They're probably going
to go to school, at least
until high school.
While in much of the
rest of the world,
they may be
completely illiterate,
have no electricity,
this kind of thing.
But there is a commonality.
And I think that too often,
we tend to measure poverty
with metrics of
income or wealth.
In many ways, the
best metric of poverty
is something like
hopelessness, or maybe it's
whether you have
books in the home,
or whether you're ever
read to, whether there's
any affection in the home
as you're growing up.
And there are an awful
lot of kids growing up
in America that,
by that measure,
are as poor as any in the world.
There are all kinds
of pathologies
that come with poverty that
make it a lot harder to address
than just a money issue.
And it was
heartbreaking reporting
on some of these things.
There was one-- in
the opening clip
you saw there was one little
boy, a four-year-old boy named
Johnny.
He can't speak.
Why can't he speak?
Because he had a hearing
problem early on in life,
probably from untreated
ear infections.
And so they weren't caught.
He wouldn't get a
hearing screening.
And so as his brain
is developing,
he's not getting
any auditory input,
so that he doesn't
develop speech.
And finally, it's caught
later on by Save the Children.
Thank God they were
there to do it.
And we still don't know
whether he will ever fully
be able to recover.
An idea that this happens,
that a kid like Johnny
can fall through the
cracks in this country,
through something as simple as
missing a hearing screening,
is just shattering when you
see a little kid like that.
And I hope that one thing that
viewers will get from "A Path
Appears" when they
see them is we
have this narrative in this
country about how poverty
is about personal
irresponsibility.
There's no doubt that
that is sometimes true,
that there are certainly
some poor people who
are irresponsible, and there
is self-destructive behavior
that sometimes
goes with poverty.
But not always.
And you get a four-year-old
kid who has done nothing wrong.
And yet he is going to
be disadvantaged, perhaps
for the rest of his life,
because we dropped the ball.
We as a society dropped
the ball in providing
hearing screenings.
And that's an irresponsibility
that is not Johnny's.
It's ours.
CHERIE HANNOUCHE:
I think that story
and obviously, Savannah's story,
as well, are so shattering.
And they are so overwhelming
that a lot of times people
wonder, what can I do?
How can I actually
make a real difference?
And you mentioned before, there
are many different levels where
people can actually effectively
participate and join
the conversation.
What I love about the
documentary, but also the book,
is that there are clear
stats that you have,
which speak to what
people can actually do.
One that I keep
with me every day
is that if everyone just
gave up their morning coffee,
$220 billion would go
back into these issues.
I'd love to hear from
you guys, and I'm sure
the audience, as well--
just other stats or things
that are really eye-opening,
that can talk to certain change
that we can make.
MIRA CHANG: You should talk
to that, from in the book.
NICHOLAS KRISTOF: You know, some
of the stats that really struck
me are just about the
cost-effectiveness
of addressing some
of these issues.
We tend to think
that it's hopeless.
And I think that's one
reason why we tune out.
Maybe one problem of
us as journalists,
and also the
humanitarian community ,
is we focus so much on the
problems that we lead people
to think that all
there are is problems.
That there isn't progress.
There has been
progress, and we do
have some evidence-based
interventions that will work.
And so one of the things we
emphasize, both in the book
and in the
documentary, is what's
called home visitation
programs, which basically
work with at-risk
parents and at-risk kids
very early in life,
beginning in pregnancy,
up to the first
few years of life.
And it's to encourage
pregnant women
to try to avoid alcohol,
try to avoid drugs.
After the birth, think about
if you want birth control, then
here's how you might go about
getting it for a next child.
Encourage breastfeeding.
Encourage talking to a child.
A child on welfare will
have heard 30 million
fewer words by age four than
a child of professionals.
30 million more words.
And so they begin to
speak at the same time,
but because of that gap
that child on welfare
is going to be less
prepared for school.
The verbal parts of
that child's brain
are going to be less developed.
It's a huge impediment.
And so there are these
home visitation programs
that coach these parents
on these elements
of early childhood rearing.
And the result is
that, even though they
end at-- the one that was
studied most ends at age two.
By age 15, those
kids are only half as
likely to have been arrested.
And because juvenile
incarceration
is incredibly expensive,
$110,000 a year,
this program, every
dollar invested in it
pays for itself
seven times over.
And so we would not only
be doing a huge benefit
to these kids and
to these moms, we
would be saving public
money on a major scale.
And yet this
program-- it's called
Nurse-Family Partnership--
it still only reaches
that 2% of the kids
who need it in the US.
And that's another example
where poverty is indeed,
in some sense, about
personal responsibility.
But that irresponsibility,
in part, is that of society
and not actually implementing
evidence-based programs
that would make
a real difference
and would pay for themselves
multiple times over.
MIRA CHANG: And
just to add on that,
because I'm big on the early
intervention part, also--
is that a lot of the
issues that we talk about,
both in "Half the Sky"
and "A Path Appears"--
sex trafficking, domestic
violence, teenage pregnancy--
we tend to think about them
as very discreet issues.
OK, let's just talk about
domestic violence right now.
Let's just talk about this.
But actually, if you
really think about
where these women, and
men, and kids come from,
and what their backgrounds are,
there are so many similarities.
And a lot of them
have to do with what
if you could intervene
a little earlier?
What if you can remove
some of the vulnerability
that they're facing
as a young child?
What if the moms, when
they're having the babies,
know how to raise their
babies, or give them
a better shot at both
medical care or education?
I think it has an impact on
all of these different things
that we are talking about
and are worried about.
So we should invest earlier.
CHERIE HANNOUCHE: Great.
Well, before-- I want to make
sure we have time to open it up
to Q&A-- before we do
that, I just wanted to ask,
can you share with us what's
the secret to maintaining
the optimism?
And looking at any secrets
that-- when you read or watch
the film, you can see that with
all of the different advocates.
And you can see it even in
the trailer, as well-- some
of those happy moments, as well.
NICHOLAS KRISTOF:
People always think,
because I spend a lot of time
covering genocide, and poverty,
and sex trafficking,
that I must be
kind of deeply depressed, and
greatly traumatized, and very
fragile.
And the truth is that, sure--
in reporting these things,
you see some really
terrible things.
But side by side with
the worst of humanity,
you typically see the very best.
You see incredible courage,
incredible resilience.
You see people who are
making a difference
and empowering people,
providing opportunity,
and you also see an
element of progress.
When I first-- and
I think this maybe
is something that
we in journalism
need to figure out better, how
to tell the story of-- when
I first began traveling around
Africa as a backpacking law
student, what really struck
me was the blindness.
And there were so many
middle-aged people who,
from river blindness, cataracts,
trachoma, could not see,
could not work, could not
look after their kids.
And for the book, we
talked to a woman in Mali
who had had trachoma, which
is an incredibly painful way
to go blind, for eight
years, had lost two kids
because she couldn't
raise food for them.
And then she got a $40
surgery through Helen Keller
International, which is
right here in New York. $40
surgery from a nurse,
20 minute operation.
And then they're helping
her up off the table.
And so, are you OK?
Do you want us to walk
you back to your home?
She says, get out of my way.
I can see now.
I can look after myself.
$40-- I mean, that's
not depressing.
That's inspiring,
what we can do.
And on the whole,
that is happening.
It's just not
happening fast enough.
CHERIE HANNOUCHE: Thanks.
Great.
Let's open it up to the audience
to ask a couple questions.
The mics are on both sides.
AUDIENCE: Thank you guys,
both, for being here.
Incredibly inspiring work.
I watched the first installment
last Tuesday, streaming on PBS.
I Chromecasted it to my TV.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: So I
actually-- Nick, I
come from "The New York Times."
My background is on the business
side of "The New York Times,"
and I've been at Google
for three years now.
NICHOLAS KRISTOF: You've got
a better business model here.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: Well, yeah-- a
developing business model
at "The New York
Times," as well.
But being at Google,
we know a lot
about the laws of
supply and demand,
understanding that
where the demand is,
the supply will flow.
You talk a lot about that.
I'm excited to read this book
and look at it from a hopeful
perspective of what we
can do across a myriad
of different intervention
techniques, one of which
is the early childhood
intervention.
But what struck me as different
in the first installment
was the focus on
the johns, right?
This idea that if you
focus on the demand side,
that that is the nice
way to kind of circumvent
what you've been doing for
years and years and years, which
hasn't worked clearly-- which
is focusing on the supply side.
What did you see in your travels
and work around this book,
and in the
documentary, that gives
you hope that that is actually
a nice way to kind of buttress
out the work that's been done
for years by law enforcement
by focusing on the demand side?
And are you hopeful that
that's an innovation that
may be helpful in stemming
the tide of the trafficking
trend in the US and abroad?
NICHOLAS KRISTOF:
It's a great question.
And indeed, I think that
focusing on the demand side
is-- there's no
silver bullet here.
But there's silver buckshot.
And that's one of the
elements of silver buckshot
that can make a
difference on trafficking.
I'm generally a believer that
ending impunity for problems
is hugely important.
One of the things that
isn't much realized
is that there has actually
been, over the last generation,
huge progress in the US on both
domestic violence and rape,
as best we can measure them.
And the numbers are problematic.
But using victimization surveys
it looks as if both of them
have fallen by more than 50%
over the last generation.
And why is that?
A generation ago, there
was 100% impunity.
A husband could completely
beat up his wife,
a boyfriend completely
beat up his girlfriend.
The police just
would not intervene.
And most rapes are people
who know each other.
It's a boyfriend/girlfriend
situation, or former boyfriend,
whatever it may be.
And again, there,
in that situation
was almost complete impunity.
Now we know that
there is still a lot
of impunity in that situation.
But now there are enough guys
who, even though they've drunk
too much, they-- when this
girl says, no, stop here,
something still goes
on in their brain.
And they think there
might be a risk.
And that's why those
victimization rates
have gone down.
In the case of
trafficking, again, we
don't have good numbers.
But a rough estimate
is about 300,000 men
will buy sex today
somewhere in the US.
Virtually none of
them will be arrested.
You're more likely to
be hit by lightning
than you are to be
arrested while buying sex.
So there is essentially
no risk to you.
A lot of those men
have a lot to lose
if they were arrested
for buying sex.
They have reputations.
It would be a very bad thing.
If there were just a 1% or 2%
risk that they might actually
be arrested, I think
they wouldn't buy sex.
And I think you
would, in that case,
see a significant
drop in demand.
And in that case, there would
be fewer women trafficked.
And going after johns
is actually pretty easy.
We have a segment in the
doc where we, essentially--
the police department
posts an ad on Backpage
and books a hotel room.
And guys show up, and
show up, and show up,
and you arrest
them as they come.
And then it's
pretty basic stuff.
And I think that wouldn't
solve the problem.
But boy, I think it
would make a difference.
MIRA CHANG: I just
want to add, also--
so that was in Cook
County, Chicago.
And they've done a lot
in terms of trafficking
and also working
with survivor groups.
And they just finished
another Johns Day.
So there are numbers available.
And I will also say it's
a lot about what we all
think about johns
and whether or not
we think prostitution
is OK or not.
I've been to john schools
now, where people walk out,
or the johns walk
out, and they just
had no idea that A,
it was dangerous,
or B, that's the backgrounds
of some of the women
that they're engaging
in prostitution with.
And I will say,
something that I love
is there are certain
district attorney's offices
that will post the pictures
of the johns it arrests,
as it's public record.
And it's part of that idea
that if you just-- you know,
it's a shameful thing.
So if we, as a society,
understand that idea,
it'll make a dent.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Thank you for coming in.
You talked about
early intervention.
And I was just
wondering if you had
any comments about parental
leave in this country,
as comparison with
other places, and how
that might have an effect
on early intervention.
NICHOLAS KRISTOF:
You know, we don't
have good research on that.
It makes sense that
parental leave would help.
Maternal attachment--
there was one study that
found that maternal attachment
at 18 months to a child
was a better predictor of high
school graduation than IQ was.
So there's pretty good evidence
that there is a correlation.
It would make sense that
a mom or a dad to who
is going to be
around is going to be
more likely to have
that kind of attachment.
But we don't have,
to my knowledge,
rigorous evidence on that.
What we do know is that
access to parental leave
seems to leave working class
moms more likely to stay
in the labor force, which is a
good way of fighting poverty.
I mean, a job-- I don't quote
President Reagan very much,
but one thing he was right on
is that the best social program
is a job.
And I think there's
been a misperception
that things like parental
leave will reduce employment.
And in fact, the best evidence
from Europe, for example,
is they actually boost
employment and likewise things
like paid sick leave, this kind
of thing, that they actually
boost employment by
making employment
more compatible with parenthood,
and especially single
parenthood.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
My name's Carlie.
I haven't read the book, but
I didn't read "Half the Sky"
and I found it incredibly
inspiring years ago.
My question is about, when
you say early intervention,
how does-- I don't
know if there's
any research on the
foster care system,
specifically in New York City.
Do you find that a lot of
children who get caught up
in the trafficking are runaways,
or perhaps in foster care
that is inadequate?
Just curious how that plays
a role in the equation.
MIRA CHANG: Oh, it's huge.
Absolutely.
I mean, a lot of the
organizations that we feature
in the series deal specifically
with foster care kids,
or throwaways, or runaways,
because those are definitely
the most vulnerable demographic.
Because they don't have the
guidance, or the mentorship,
or the confidence,
really, to be able to know
what to do in a situation when
they're approached by someone.
Runaways, in particular.
If you're on the street,
you don't have any money,
you don't have any
place to go to,
and it is a dangerous,
dangerous world out there.
Because there are
a lot of people
that know how easy it
is to sell other people.
Do you want to say
anything about it?
NICHOLAS KRISTOF:
One of the programs
that has a really good
record-- and again, it's
been done with randomized
control trials,
really a kind of
evidence-based attempt--
is called Youth Villages.
And what it does is, because
often, foster parent success
rates aren't great, and
institutional rates aren't
great, that what they
do is try to provide
strong support to
that child's family.
Or if the mom and dad aren't
appropriate, or in jail,
or whatever, then to find
some other relative who
may be willing to
take that child in.
So that it's at least part
of the extended family
and then provide them
support and coaching
to make it more feasible.
And that has worked much better.
There does seem to be this
yearning for family ties.
And it's now being introduced
by more and more states
because it saves money, again.
Because then they're
spending less money
on these juvenile
detention centers,
which are incredibly expensive.
And the outcomes are also
better for these kind
of extended
family-based programs.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
My name's Bianca Levy.
I'm a fan of yours
and Charles's work.
My question's about
the Super Bowl.
It's one of the most
dangerous times of year,
in terms of sex
trafficking, yet there
seems to be very little
awareness about it.
So what do we know about human
trafficking around the Super
Bowl, and what preventative
measures are being done,
or do you think should
be done, to prevent this?
There's actually something
of a debate about this.
And the conventional
wisdom has been
that there's a lot
of trafficking,
that Super Bowl tends to
be a hub for trafficking.
And it makes intuitive
sense, but there
have been some studies of
trying to look at ads for sex
on Backpage.com in cities where
the Super Bowl is being held.
And I think I've come across
three different studies
of this, and they come to
somewhat mixed results.
But they don't seem to suggest
that it is nearly as much
of a hub for trafficking as
the conventional wisdom is.
And I don't know enough
about the underlying reasons
for that.
It is true that, generally,
convention cities
tend to be a time
when people go online
and buy-- 10% of American men
in one survey had purchased sex
online in the previous year.
It's a huge thing.
But that connection with the
Super Bowl, at least to me,
is somewhat elusive.
AUDIENCE: Hi there.
Thanks for being here.
My name's Eleanor.
And as an avid "Law
and Order" fan,
I'm curious about how we can use
and leverage popularized media.
Be it like movies
or a television
and to educate
America and elsewhere
about these very pressing
issues around domestic violence,
around sex
trafficking, and rape.
And I'm curious if you've
done work with that before,
or what your thoughts are on
leveraging and media as a way
to shift the mindset, where
maybe law and policy might
be slower to do so.
NICHOLAS KRISTOF:
I'm a huge believer
in exactly what you're saying.
And I come to this
reluctantly, because I
have-- a scribbler is a
kind of disdain for TV,
oh, we're above that.
And yet-- and then I came
across a pretty amazing pair
of studies, one in
Brazil and one in India.
And I've always really believed
that girls' education is
the way you really
transform a society.
That is the incredible
elixir of changing minds.
And then there was
one study in India
that looked at what happens
when television arrives
in a rural village
for the first time,
and change in attitudes
in that village.
And it found that six months
of television in a village
is equivalent to-- I forget--
four years of education,
or something, in
terms of attitudes.
Towards domestic violence.
Towards whether
a woman should be
able to leave the house
without her husband.
This kind of thing.
And it seemed to be that people
had very traditional attitudes
in these villages.
And then these TV shows
essentially showed middle class
urban families, where
the woman was educated,
where she was not
getting beaten up,
where she was leaving the house.
And that because it was kind
of high status families,
that tended to-- villagers
kind of respected it.
And something similar in Brazil.
And then here, in
this country, one
of the things that has
particularly vexed me
is the problem of
teen pregnancy--
that 30% of American
teenage girls
become pregnant by age 19.
30%.
And that is down now 51%,
since the modern peak in 1991.
Well, what brought it down
from that modern peak?
One of the factors was "16
and Pregnant," the TV show,
by essentially showing teenage
girls this is what pregnancy
and being a mom is like.
I can't say that I
watched the show,
but I gather that
was the takeaway.
And so I love my perch on the
Op Ed page of "The New York
Times," but I do think
that people come up
with plot lines on
some of these shows
in ways that aren't didactic,
and aren't heavy-handed,
but maybe it can send a message.
And Neal Baer has done
this incredibly well
with some of his TV shows.
I think that may be
a really powerful way
to open minds and hearts.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
CHERIE HANNOUCHE: We've got
time for one more question.
AUDIENCE: So you said at the
beginning of the trailer,
how poverty is at the
root of all of this.
I Can you explain more about
how poverty plays a role?
MIRA CHANG: I can
start with the idea
that one thing that we
kept trying to unveil,
this idea that
poverty is not just
a financial or
dollar kind of idea.
It's really a vicious cycle
that is difficult to get out of,
whether you're in Colombia
or you're in West Virginia.
And so as we-- you've
known this for a long time,
you've been telling me stories.
But as we were filming
and actually collecting
these stories, you just heard
the same patterns over and over
again.
Whether our story
was trafficking
or whether our story
was domestic violence,
there were similarities
in terms of how
poverty and the
lack of opportunity
contributed to that kind
of vulnerability that
led to certain abuses.
NICHOLAS KRISTOF: Yeah.
In Tulsa, Oklahoma,
we met a family.
The girl-- it was a small girl.
Her mom was 13 when she had her.
Her mom, the grandmother,
was 14 when she had her.
The great-grandmother was
13 when she'd had her.
You had this cycle and when
you have babies having babies,
then that's not good for either
the mom or for the child.
It's more likely to lead to
a lack of maternal attachment
in childhood to
the child hearing
fewer of these words being
spoken, less talking--
MIRA CHANG: Nutrition--
NICHOLAS KRISTOF: To
the nutrition issues,
to sometimes self-medication.
In West Virginia,
20% of kids now
are born with alcohol or
narcotics in their system.
20%.
And those kids, they're
not at the starting line.
And so then people, partly
because they self-medicate,
they get an arrest.
And then once you have
a criminal record,
you become even less employable.
You get then-- one thing the
conservatives were essentially
right about and
liberals wrong about,
over the last
generation or two, was
the importance of
families for raising kids.
And there's evidence that
boys, in particular-- it really
matters if a dad is at home.
And I think conservatives
were right on that.
They were absolutely wrong
about mass incarceration.
Mass incarceration--
by quintupling
the number of
people behind bars,
we dramatically reduce the
number of dads at home.
And so you have all
these issues swirling
around that make it a lot
harder for these kids.
And it's not exactly poverty
in the sense of low income,
but poverty in its
broader sense of just not
seeing a trajectory out.
Not getting the support,
not having that access
to economic and social mobility
and access to education
that is the best
escalator out of poverty.
CHERIE HANNOUCHE: I know
that whole the focus on that
is also something that
will be airing tonight,
and a big part of
tonight's episode.
So I encourage everybody
to watch tonight,
and also next Monday,
at 10 PM on PBS.
Thank you so much,
Nicholas and Mira.
There are books that
Nicholas signed in the back,
as well, if you're interested.
But thank you so much
for joining us today.
NICHOLAS KRISTOF: Thanks a lot
MIRA CHANG: Thanks
for having us.
Appreciate it.
[APPLAUSE]